الصين
متصدرين الاخبار والعناوين السبب هو طبعا
طفرت كورونا جديده في الصين وخروج الجائحه
عن السيطره في بعض المناطق فامس اعلنت
بكين وفاه حالهن بكرونا وبالتالي صار عدد
الوفيات من اسابيع خمس وفيات هذا غير
الارتفاع في عدد حالات الاصابه بكوب 19
بشكل متسارع ومقلق فامس عدد الحالات 2000
حاله الصيدليات بتشكوا من نقص الادويه
محارق الجثث ملحقه على الوفيات ودول
العالم بدات تحذر من تاثير هذا التفشي على
باقي العالم المصيبه كمان انه في علماء او
بيقولوا انه هذه موجه اولى من بين ثلاث
موجات متوقعينها تضرب الصين في الشتاء
والسبب التفشي الجديده الان مو محدد او
معروف لكن الصين من اسابيع رفعت كل
الاجراءاتها وقودها صار ما لمواجهه كورونا
واللي فرضتها من ثلاث سنوات ورفعتها فوط
قطط مظاهرات اتخلى لها شغب وعنف كبيرين من
الشعب اللي خلاص صراحه يعني وصل حده ومعاد
متحمل لنفسيا ولا اقتصاديا ولا اجتماعيا
ولا باي شكل يعني ومن بعد اسابيع كانت في
فيديوهات المظاهرات والاحتجاجات ضد قيد
كورونا في الصين ماليه المنصات اليوم من
السيطر فيديوهات موجعه على القلب صراحه من
مستشفيات ومراكز صحيه
اليوم
[موسيقى]
وكمان في فيديوهات متداوله على المنصات ما
بتختلف قسوتها عن اللي شفتوهم قبل وكمان
الفيديو حاصل على مليونير مشاهده وهو لجثث
كثيره مرميه في المستشفيات اللي ما عاد
قادره خلاص انها تستقبل حالات زياده
فرونسي
[موسيقى]